lauritz would you outsource your social
media marketing yeah I mean I definitely
think you know you can pretty much
outsource a lot of things if you really
need to I mean there's so many um
agencies out there that create content
they do social and it definitely is
helpful though if you are considering
outsourcing your social is to you know
make sure you have a conversation with
whoever is going to be doing your social
and make sure that they understand your
brand what you stand for who your
audience is and that'll help them on you
know be able to capture your voice your
tone how they should speak to your
audience and you know to make sure that
it's it's a smooth transition and you
know it shouldn't seem like somebody
else is doing the posting for you and it
should all be it should all be fairly
smooth and I think you know having that
conversation will be really important if
that's something you want to pursue yeah
I would recommend one starting to do
some things yourself so you have an
understanding because this is so
important right this could help
transform your business and I wouldn't
just blindly give it off to somebody
else to do I would have an understanding
of it at least even if you don't become
the expert on it just to have an
understanding and be reachable you know
as a CEO of the business you should have
a Twitter account that people can reach
you out in ping you I that you can
respond from even if it's not your main
company one if you were going to
outsource it I'm not a huge fan of
giving it to another company what i
would do is bring on somebody to work at
my business I would bring on a monica
right so that you know the found of a
weber doesn't have to be out there
creating the content he could hire
somebody super talented like monica to
come in and create the content and do
these interviews and be on youtube and
write write the blogs and all of that
stuff that goes along with grading
context but you know she's there she's
at a weber you know she's got aj the
astronaut behind her you know she lives
the culture she gets it you know they
hired her for a reason uh that would be
my step instead of trying to go to an
agency because I think it's hard for
agencies to really digest your brand
they don't live it and breathe it like
you do and so one I would say you know
you
to try it at least I have a general
understanding of it and then if you were
going to outsource it I would bring it
to somebody inside the business either
as a part-time role or full-time role
depending on what you can afford but
yeah you got to make sure to monica's
points that they can capture your voice
understand what you stand for can bring
that out into every post because a lot
of people are just dumping a coupon
codes and hey check out this article and
and it's not actually providing a lot of
value because doesn't have a lot of meat
to it it's gotta have some meats gotta
have some heart and that heart comes
from you know ideally you but if not you
then your team because they understand
what it's all about